dès les premiers jours du confinement la
mairie de pommevic à distribuer à ses
habitants des attestations de
déplacement imprimé par ses soins le
conseil municipal a aussi mis en place
un réseau de solidarité
chaque élu a la charge d'un secteur de
la collectivité et doit veiller sur les
personnes les plus vulnérables
ils peuvent par exemple leur faire des
courses ou se rendent pour eux à la
pharmacie celle ordonnée
c'est notre objectif celui de être
disponible vis-à-vis de la population en
fonction de l'heure de leur sang
boulangerie dans le village les
habitants doivent faire 10 km pour aller
chercher du pain et potentiellement
s'exposer aux coronavirus dans les
supermarchés pour éviter de prendre ce
risque la mairie a mis à disposition la
salle des fêtes pour qu'un artisan
boulanger puisse fournir les administrés
ça c'est un petit biscuit habile et
cacao avec tout ça c'est répondant par
avance sa fonction de bien et ça
correspondait à un besoin ya une attente
ce qui était intéressant par rapport à 7
à cette initiative c'était de mettre à
la disposition locales pour que le point
de vente puisse se faire dans de bonnes
conditions à la fois sanitaire et
sécuritaire palier isolement des
personnes âgées seules ou encore
organiser la solidarité entre les
habitants
depuis le début du confinement les
collectivités locales ont su faire
preuve d'innovation pour maintenir du
lien social